[Music]
okay fine I know this guy's been
watching me this is the $1400 Samsung
Galaxy S 20 ultra with one of the
craziest zoom lenses on a smartphone to
date this is Michael McKeever a New York
City private investigator Private Eye
for over 30 years I work in the street
lot I do a lot of surveillance so being
out of my car and getting pictures of
people without them knowing that's
another thing really sure having a
better zoom lens has some appeal in
everyday life yeah for birding and
things but I couldn't think of a real
reason anyone needed an a hundred X zoom
on their smartphone except of course if
your job is to watch people without them
knowing so we had mike test in three
situations to see how the galaxy s 20
ultra compares to the iPhone 11 Promax
his go-to Sony camcorder and the $1,000
Nikon Coolpix P 1,000
test one from a car into an apartment
window the distance about 50 feet okay
maybe I set the scene inside a bit this
samsung takes an awesome picture we
wouldn't normally be shooting into
someone's apartment like this but it is
an impressive camera turns out P eyes
don't really shoot into people's homes
because it can break privacy laws when
comparing shots it was nuts how much
better the Samsung was compared to the
iPhone that's because the galaxy s 20 as
this new telephoto lens with what
Samsung calls a folded zoom mechanism it
uses the phone's three lenses to create
10x hybrid optical zoom
then magnifies that for a hundred X
digital zoom that's a lot of marketing
jargon but what you need to know is that
shots between 10x and 30x are crisp
shots up to a hundred X not so much but
the quality of the pictures is good
until you get to the really max zoom as
you may have guessed that Nikon - 125 X
optical zoom produced a crazy clear
image just look at the detail in my
earring the Sony with its 30x optical
zoom wasn't too shabby either test tube
a moving subject distance about 150 C
what need to go to the hundred it's hard
to find her in the frame the results
it's so hard to take a shot of a moving
object past the 30 X setting the tripod
I would never do unless I was a wedding
photographer maybe
and even then the shots at 30x were
clearer and said a lot more about the
scene nothing beat the nikon though for
getting the action of the pic for moving
shots like this
mike prefers his camcorder and i see why
by the way it was a scratch not a pic
test three text on a computer swing
distant about 15 feet i wrote the first
line in 14.5 ii in 24 point the results
the galaxy s 20 ultra can really capture
some things you may not want people
seeing on your screen
it's good the quality of the pictures is
good as far as the magnification that
30x is really good would really be
useful and while the quality isn't as
good as the Nikon or even Mike's trusty
camcorder it's a heck of a lot more
discreet
would I buy one I would buy one yeah I
mean I'm kind of you know laughing on an
Apple now with so many things but yeah
it's definitely it's definitely an
improvement I think as far as cameras go
I agree and the shots are really
impressive for a smartphone but do we
want everyone to have P eye tools in
their pocket some guys focus on trying
to get the best equipment I don't really
ascribe to that I feel like Eric
Clapton's not a great guitar player
because he bought the most expensive
guitar in the world has to do with the
skill the operator still I'd close the
windows